hi good afternoon and welcome to this
talk about
board support packages for yocto project
so
first of all
how many of you are users of yocto
project at the moment
some
okay
um anybody maintaining a bsp here for
yokto
[Laughter]
one maybe
cool
okay
so
this oh first of all a little bit about
a bit about myself so i'm chris simmons
i've been doing stuff with embedded
linux since 1999.
um i've written a book on the subject
it's a good book just saying
and
you can contact me by electronic means
by
these various channels
however
so this target then is going to be about
board support packages and yocto
um
[Music]
so in yocto
the board support package is written as
a meta layer and i'll explain what that
is later on for those of you who are not
yokto regular users
so every project needs a bsp because the
bsp defines the hardware
okay you pretty much can't do anything
without a bsp of some kind
um so where do you get the bsp from
uh the bsp either comes from the guy who
sold you the board
um which could be a raspberry pi for
example
or it could be a commercial board from
one of the many companies that make uh
embedded boards
or if you are that guy
who provides the board then you're going
to have to write the bsp yourself or if
you're developing in-house hardware
then somebody's gonna have to produce
the bsp for that board
either way the bsp is the foundation of
the stack of layers you need to make the
the software work so the bsp is i
believe the most important part of the
whole thing
so this is all about how to write a bsp
what is good what is bad about what goes
into bsp layers
but before we get into that i want to
do a bit of a
a prefix talk a little bit about yokto
and what yocto is and how the various
bits put together so i want to
in particular i want to give you the
terminology so when we talk about layers
and recipes
um and bb pens we all know what those
things really mean
so youtube project um there's the url
um
so yogto project is a build system that
creates
um a linux distro for you
uh
with the octo you feed in
a configuration and a bunch of recipes
and then it magically munches that all
together and produces first of all
binary packages
in a form in some format usually rpm but
it doesn't really matter
and then it combines those binary
packages into images
and then you flash those images into the
flash memory of your target device or
put them onto an sd card or whatever it
is your device supports
um
so yokto oh an open embedded i should
mention open embedded here because just
in case any opening embedded guys are
watching this
so
youngtow project and open embedded are
kind of the same but also somewhat
different
open embedded actually was the um
the the start of all this 2003 open
embedded was started
uh yokto
project is kind of a fork of that uh
which came along in 2010
for complicated reasons which i'm not
going to go into now
but yokto and embedded open embedded
kind of the same thing
but also different let's just leave it
um
yeah
well okay so why do you want to do this
why didn't we just take debian
or um
yeah distro of your choice
and the reason is that if you do take
debian as you do with the raspberry pi
with raspberry and or now raspberry pi
os as it's now called
the problem with with with a full-blown
desktop distro is it brings on board a
whole bunch of stuff you don't really
want
it's difficult to
um
to split debian up into small enough
pieces for a really good embedded uh
deployment you end up with a bunch of
stuff you don't need
you end up with
more attack service than you really need
you end up with maintenance problems and
so on
so
in the general case debian is not a good
choice for an embedded operating system
for those reasons
so let's talk about yokto
uh so yocto has a six month release
cycle
um we're currently at 3.3
uh with the codename hard knot
um but it will soon in the next couple
of weeks be superseded by 3.4 which is
just about to be released and that has
the code name hollister
and you can see the previous
versions as well
every now and again there is a long-term
support release
so the lts release is 3.1 which is done
fell which actually is from april last
year
so how do you get yokto
uh well you go to
uh this git repository
and you do a git clone
and
minus b in whichever branch you want or
if you want the main branch leave leave
out the minus b bit
that will download for you
total of about 250 megabytes of which 55
megabytes is the actual metadata
okay so not so much
why so small that's because what you've
downloaded is just the metadata
the recipes
you don't download the code at this
point it's only when you do the build
that it downloads the code for the
packages that you want
so after you've done the git clone it
will by default clone into a directory
called pokey
again there's reasons why it's called
which i really don't go into just
now it just is
and then within that uh directory you
will find there's a script
called oe init build end
oe for open embedded
so you need to source that script in
order to set up various shell variables
and that will create for you a build
directory if it doesn't exist already
you can give the name of the directory
you want it to create here as a
parameter
if you don't give a parameter there
by default it's called build
and then within that build directory
there is a configuration directory
called conf
and there's a bunch of configuration
files in there the main one is called
local.conf
and it's within the local.conf you set
up what it is you want to build
so you have to go and edit this with a
text editor
um
typically you will put things in here
like machine equals something or other
so if i'm building for a beaglebone i
specify beaglebone if i'm building for a
raspberry pi i put raspberry pi
so that actually is the board support
package so this is the bit we're going
to be talking about is
what is what do we mean by beaglebone or
raspberry pi
what does that point to
you can also select the distribution
the default one is called pocky
and the distribution is basically the
policy
of which
components you want to download and
install
so do you want the latest of everything
or do you want to have a conservative
approach to the packages you install
uh which net demon do you want to use
um which
graphics environment do you want to use
and so on so the distro is
policy when we've got a choice of
packages which one should we install
package class this allows you to specify
the intermediate packaging format
the default is rpm
and to be honest there's no good reason
to ever change that
so we kind of leave that
and then there are various other things
including extra image features
it's documented i'm not going to go into
details here
um but this pretty much does what it
says it allows you to add additional
things in so for example a good one to
do when you're developing stuff is
adding debug tweaks
that will add in um
gdb and i can't remember a few other uh
useful debug tools
so the core of the
um yocto project metadata
are called recipes
uh so we have recipes
these recipes are gathered together into
layers
and then there's a tool called bit bake
which is the task scheduler which
processes the recipes and will perform
whatever instructions are needed
so bitbake will generate binary packages
in rpm format by default
and then as a final step when it when it
generates the image it will take
the rpm files and unpack them to create
images
and then those images are flashed into
your flash memory
so just as a random example then this is
what a recipe looks like
this is the
canonical hello world
recipe
um
what can i say so the first bit is just
fluff we can ignore the first three
things natural fact
oh no so first two things
the third thing is the license the
license is important every recipe must
have a license
okay we believe in licenses licenses are
very important
not only much is say that it's an mit
license
you must also give a pointer to the file
or a file that contains the text of that
license
and we also have an md5 hash of that
file just to make sure that nobody has
gone and changed the license when you
weren't looking
so licenses are important
next bit down here with how a line that
says source uri
so this is a list of
places to get the source code for
the component that you're going to
compile
usually in source uri
this will point to a tar file
on some server somewhere so you'll have
source uri is https colon slash
some uri some url slash some tar file
or you could be a git repository so
you'd have git colon slash slash and
then
a git root git repo
but in this case because this is a
simple hello world program we are just
using the local
mime type file colon slash so that is a
local file actually
packaged as part of the recipe
then we have instructions to compile
this thing
so do compile
that's the instruction that bitbait uses
to compile stuff and so in here we
specify how we build this thing
this is a simple um cc so we're just
doing gonna run the compiler we're gonna
compile helloworld.c and we're gonna
generate a binary called hello world
usually you'd have a make file here or
something but you know this is this is
simple
and then there's a do in store section
which says having built hello world
where do you put it so we want to put it
into something called bindiya
bindiya turns out to be user slash bin
so this is going to install it into
this is going to do an install minus m
hello world and it goes into binder so
we'll end up with user bin hello world
there are other things for other useful
places as well as binder like libraries
and such like
which i think is called libdia
okay so that's roughly speaking what a
recipe looks like
um
yeah you get the basic idea idea now i
hope
so in
open embedded stroke doctor project
we have first of all we have the
configuration file i just mentioned so
in build conf you have this local.conf
file which specifies your machine and
your distro
and there's another file called
bblayers.conf
so that is the list of layers in your
project
and for example we have here a couple of
layers so a layer is just a directory
which contains bb files
by some convention
the layers are prefixed with meta
so we have meta this and meta that the
the most meta one of the wall of the
mall is just called meta so that's the
the really basic stuff
and then meta pokey is the
uh recipes for the pocky distro
and we'll see in a moment or two your
board support package will be its own
meta layer
and then within the layers so these are
just directories and they just can
contain a whole bunch of bb files and a
few other things which we'll come to in
a moment
now
the idea of layers is really powerful
because it means that we can just build
up our project by adding in layers for
whatever it is we want to do
so you'll always start off with the meta
layer because that's always required
you'll need a distro layer for example
metapokey you'll need a bsp layer
but there are hundreds and hundreds of
other layers you can just add in as you
need them
oh okay just for reference this is what
the bblayers.com file looks like well
it's a list of directories
it's not complicated
okay so that's the basic structure of
uh yocto project
so now let's look at the layers and in
particular support package layers
so there's what i call the trinity
trinity
the holy trinity of um
open embedded and yocto project
this stroke machine image
so the distro is how i want to build my
system that's the policy which versions
of of packages do i want to use
uh that kind of thing
so high level stuff
the machine
this variable is the board in other
words the board support package i want
to use
and then the image is
the the image recipe i will use when i
build the target images
now the neat thing about this is you can
swap any of these things around
and it should in theory at least still
work
so say i have several boards
that are that i'm producing
they could be different architectures
one could be arm one could be x86
one could be
risk five
yes risk five is popular these days
so long as you have a board support
package for each of those
you can just specify the machine here
leave the disto and the image the same
and you'll get the same thing built for
these different architectures
or in a similar way you can just change
the image
so we can have one image that is just
bare metal
we can have another image which has a
graphical environment
we can have another image that's for
pre-production tests or whatever
so we keep the distro and this machine
the same we just change the image for
whatever it is we want to do with that
particular board
so it becomes very powerful
and modular
which is quite neat
so layers so there are three types of
layer
bsp distro
and everything else
the bsp layers then
they define a machine variable so the
way you know it's a bsp layer is it has
this file here in conf slash machine
slash something dot conf
and where i put machine in brackets that
just is the name of the board which
could be raspberry pi or beaglebone or
whatever
uh distro layers you can tell it's a
destroy layer because it has a directory
called distro and a conf file in there
if it has neither
then it is an everything else
so these are often just called software
layers so this is stuff that is not
distro or board specific
so
libraries
qt qt5
meta qg5 is a layer for example
languages there's a meta java layer
virtualization se linux there's a metase
linux actually meta security is for sr
linux
and so on
and there is i don't think i've got it
on the slide but there is a
website you can go to called
uh open embedded layer index
layer index open embedded can't quite
remember but google it um which lists
out
three or four hundred of layers like
this
plus there are private layers
that you will get
you you will find links to from various
places
so like i said the layer concept is
really really powerful
yes
you may have occurred it may occur to
you in my description of that there is a
fourth option
you can have a layer which has both a
machine and a distro configuration
we do not talk about these
they should not exist
um they do exist but really they
shouldn't
so
if you find you have a layer which has
both of these things
yeah something somewhere's gonna gone
wrong
and you really need to refactor it
okay so
so let's talk about bsps and i what i
want to do from from now to the end of
the presentation is to go through
some of the things not everything
because that we don't have that much
time but some of the things you'll find
that are specific to bsp layers
and i want to kind of
point to the best practice when you're
laying out the bsp
or conversely even if you're not writing
the bsp i want you to recognize a good
bsp when you see one
and that's just as important
so first rule of bsp layers keep it
simple
and this is probably the biggest problem
quite often there is too much stuff put
into the bsp layer the bsp layer should
have
the machine configuration file so that's
the thing in uh conf slash machine
whatever.conf
and it should have configuration for
your bootloader whatever that might be
the kernel version you want to use and
any modules that there requires
maybe some firm firmware binaries that
you need to build the system up
uh for various bits and pieces
other hardware related stuff so maybe
gstreamer libraries for the particular
video controller you have that kind of
thing
and nothing else
so it should only contain hardware
specific stuff there should not be any
generic stuff in here at all that
belongs in a different layer
and meta raspberry pi actually is a good
example if you are building a bsp
go see what meta raspberry pi have done
that's a that's a very good template
so um
yeah i kind of stepped through a couple
of things so
supposing i am producing a range of
boards
uh called nova
uh they're called nova because they're
new they're sparkling
and also they explode for no well
understood reason from time to time
we're working on that
so i go bitbit layers
create layer
metanova is a good name for it
so all that does actually is create a
directory
so that creates my directory called
metanova with a couple of subdirectories
in it
and then i need to add that layer
sometime pipbig layers add layer
metanova
it's now part of my bb layers uh
conf file and any recipes i create in
that metanova directory will be part of
my project
it will generate for you when you do the
create layer it will generate a template
readme file
um
it's good practice to actually put
something sensible into that readme file
to explain
what the layer is for which boards do
you support
any other interesting stuff to anybody
using this layer
and a license everything has to have a
license
uh including the layer metadata
most people choose an mit license for
them for the
layer metadata but of course you can
choose whichever license you like
and then you would want to create the
configuration files for your hardware
so
in conf slash machine
within metanova
we will create two files
because we have the nova and the nova
pro which we're very proud of
uh so we have two configuration files
one for uh the two boards because
they're they're sufficiently different
that a single configuration wouldn't
cover them both
and then when i do a build of course
uh i select which machine i'm using by
putting it into my local.conf file
machine equals
nova nova pro for example
then we start populating the
nova.com file
probably one of the places i want to
start is the bootloader how do i boot my
board
uh most likely i'm using u-boot
so i put extra image depends plus equals
u-boot
pretty much job done
so this variable here extra image
depends is a list of packages that need
to be built
but not included in the final root file
system
because the bootloader is separate from
that
it's quite likely that i will need to
configure u-boot for my nova board
um and the way you would do that is
through something called a bb append
so i will create also in my metanova
i'll create a u-boot some version bb
append
and there i'll put in the stuff that's
specific to my configuration
so that may contain some additional
configuration files for uboot
may contain some patches to add some
drivers or something for my board
whatever
and i've chosen um
a version number so 2021
0 1.
so let's talk a little bit then as a
digression what about these version
numbers
so every recipe has a version number
so with u-boot
u-boot is the name of the package
and then the version number is usually
expressed like this with an underscore
and then whatever the version number
string is and it's expressed as part of
the recipe filename
there are other ways of doing it but
this is the most common way of doing it
when bit bake processes
package u-boot so back here i didn't
specify a version i just said i want you
boot
so
bitbake will simply go and use the
latest version of uber it can find
if i want a specific version and if that
version exists as a recipe somewhere i
can put preferred version underscore
name a package
say
we can also use wildcards here
so when it comes to the linux version
the linux version can have three
separate
digit fields
so we can put a percent here that's the
wild card and that will match 5.4.1 and
5.4.2 and 5.4.3 etc
okay digression number two i mentioned
bb appends just now
so let's elaborate on that a bit
so the bb append mechanism within
um open embedded is really really
powerful
it allows us to modify an existing
recipe
without actually changing the text of
the actual recipe
uh it's pretty simple
i simply need to create a so
i have u-boots u-boot some version
number
uh but for my nova board i need to add
some stuff in there specific to the
configuration for my board
so i create a file in my layer
called
same name same version dot bb append
and then in that bb append file i put my
additional stuff
when it comes to pass that it literally
uh
takes the base
um do the bb file
and literally appends
whatever is going to be
append to the end of it
and then it passes that
so this allows me to in the bb append to
override things that are defined in the
bb file
if i say wish or i can add new stuff
um i can even remove stuff if i really
want to although that's problematic
and again we can use wild cards
so
if i'm if i want my bb append to apply
to any version of u-boot not just this
particular version i can put a percent
sign in there
okay
next thing i probably want to worry
about is what kernel i'm going to am i
going to be using on my board
so i specify this again in the
uh
machine.conf file
so nova.com for example
i put preferred preferred provider
virtual kernel
so i haven't spoken about this too much
but you have these virtual packages
called virtual something one of them is
virtual candle
and you assign to the virtual package
the actual package you want to fulfill
that role
so virtual car kernel is going to be
linux nova
so that is a specific version of linux
for mine overboard
and
so preferred provider i can also give a
version number
so maybe there are several versions of
linux nova
and i specifically want the 5.10
version
that i'm using a question mark equals
for the assignment here
because
somebody can override that with a bsp in
a higher level layer so somebody may
come along and use my bsp say well this
b is great but we really want to use
5.14 or whatever the latest version
might be at the time
so bitbake assignments
we have
two forms of regular assignment
lazy and immediate
um if you're familiar with make files
this is similar to how gnu mate works
so the the lazy assignment it only
actually does the assignment when it
passes
uh the e or sorry when it
dereferences
the variable
with equals in it
um
this can be problematic because it does
mean that if you dereference the same
thing in different places
they can actually turn up with different
values sometimes
so i generally recommend people not to
use the single
the simple equals colon equals is
more deterministic
er this does an immediate assignment
when it pauses that line and once it's
been assigned it's never going to change
usually that's the behavior that you
want
and then we have the conditional
assignment
so question mark equals
means we only do the assignment if it's
not assigned already
and then there's also the double
question mark equals
which is um
no it isn't um
this is um
yeah this is the default default
so essentially what it really means is
that once we finish parsing all of the
scripts
we then actually go through with the
with the final pass and in that final
pass we do the double uh question mark
equals
so
a question mark equals overrides a
double question my equals essentially
no there isn't a triple question about
equals yet
i'm sure it's in the planning but we
haven't gotten that far yet
sonia so when we're doing assignments in
the bsp layer which is a one of the
lower level layers
it's good to use question mark equals
because someone can come along with the
bb append
and override that with a colon equals
with a different uh
value and then we'll just pick that up
when this gets processed
um
step back to the slide here before i did
the digressions there we go um
so in this case then i'm going to use my
own special kernel which i called linux
nova so this presumably is something
that i have uh cloned from
um
kernel.org and then i've got my own
special tree this is not the recommended
way of doing it by the way but it does
happen sometimes for example with
raspberry pi the raspberry pi kernel is
not the mainline kernel you have to go
and get it from raspberrypi.org
so i mentioned i've documented this
because it's kind of a simpler concept
so how do we do this i would need a
recipe called linux nova and then some
version number
and that would then have the
necessary instructions to do a git clone
from my own
nova.com
git repository or whatever
if on the other hand you're using one of
the standard kernels so there is a
standard kernel called linux yokto
i should really flip this around because
that's actually the recommended way of
doing it these days
then i would use um
i still want to make some changes but i
can do that with the bb append on linux
youtube and whichever version
uh next let's talk about device trees
this is almost certain that you will
need to modify this
so the device tree determines which hub
which bits of hardware
are active alive
and
you need to you know if you want to
remap your gpios to do certain things
you do that in the device tree so this
is one of the things you almost always
need to change
there are various ways of doing this
again i'm taking the simplest case where
we're simply going to replace the device
tree with a new one
so we have a device tree for the nova
board called nova dts
so it's in my kernel recipe
in linux nova dts
dts so that's the source for the device
tree
and then i need to
tell the kernel build
recipe
which device trees to actually build a
build time so i do that with kernel
device tree equals or color and equals
and then one or actually several device
trees if i say wished
um
it's up to you
and that will then generate for me
anova.dtb
and then later on
i would have to do some
some scripts or whatever to
tell
the bootloader u-boot to load nova dtb
at boot time
um
firmware yeah
so firmware is a real pain to be honest
so by firmware i mean the various binary
blobs that you need to program into
various bits of the system to make them
work
the example here is from the raspberry
pi actually
the
um
uh wi-fi yes this is a wi-fi chip i'm
trying but it probably does bluetooth as
well i'm not quite sure
anyhow to make this chip work you need
to load this binary into it at boot time
we don't need to do anything with that
binary we just need to load that binary
into the appropriate
location whatever it is
and away we go
so for this to happen
we need a
recipe um
called
linux form firmware
arpi distro something bb
but we also need to tell the
the build system that we need to build
this recipe which will include the
binary and then load it to boot time
does that so do this with machine extra
r recommends and then the name of that
recipe that will load the firmware for
this chip
when we boot up the wi-fi will work
how we doing yeah not too bad
um what else right
okay so there are many many many other
things i can mention
of bits and pieces you could include
into the bsp
um but i think you're getting the view
the general feel of how you do this now
so next thing i want to look at then is
the image format
so the whole point of doing all this
is to create images
and you need to determine what format of
those images you want
so
youtube has image builders for various
things the simplest is tar files
so that's just a targeted file
more sophisticated things is we can
create um partition images
uh so these can be in a regular file
format such as ext4
or they could be
probably not jf of s2 but might be ub
a flash file system format to program
into nand flash memory
or we can create a disk image
and with a disk image
that includes a partition table
maybe a boot block
and you can just flash that into emmc or
something like that or an sd card
so these days probably the last one the
disk image is the most useful one
because most devices these days come
with either
sd cards to boot from or emmc and emfc
is just a sd card with legs on that you
sold onto the board
so you select which file formats you
want
in your machine.com file
you put image fs types equals and you
can give a list so in this case i've
chosen ext3
which is a rather weird choice i can't
remember why i put that there actually
the xt4 would be more likely
or tar bz2
well why not
if i want to create a
a partitioned uh device that i can put
into a onto an sd card then i can use a
thing called wick to do that for me
funny story about wick
it actually wick actually stands for the
open image and um sorry open embedded
image creator or o-e-i-c
and then somebody realized the bible
became apparent that you you cannot
possibly pronounce oei c not in english
anyhow weak
so oik became wick
so that's why it's called wick the w
doesn't stand for anything
so
um
so you end up with a wick file
and you put it typically into the
directional wick
in your layer so in metanova in our case
there is for historical reasons there's
also another directory you can put them
in
but that would be a bit crazy
so if we want to generate a wic file
we just put
just add wic to the list of types
and then we create a wks file and we
reference it like this so now this is
for beaglebone so we have beaglebone
yokto wks that contains the the
instructions to format the image uh
ready to put into the
in the case of beaglebone the emmc
that's on the beaglebone board
i don't think
yeah okay i didn't include the stuff
about the format of wick
it's a little bit convoluted and i
didn't want to go into too much detail
there but yeah
you can look it up now now you know what
it's called you can look it up
okay so first of all the bsps keep it
simple
but obviously it's not that simple
because it's a complicated thing you're
doing
so keep it as simple as possible
the second rule of bsps then is don't
break things and this is where
the
things tend to go wrong
um
yeah so let me go through some of the
pitfalls and some of the things you
should look out for
the first issue then is that
the person creating the bsp layer
in some
well-known company or other
probably isn't thinking about products
you may be using from for example
competitors
they will assume you're always going to
use their product
and never can use any other product
that is not the case of course
so one of the issues is that quite often
bsp layers are written
in such a way that they destroy
everything else
so as long as you're using that
particular board
fine
but if you want um if you have a bsp
sorry if you have a yakuto set up with
multiple bsps and you just want to
select the bsp by setting the machine
then you'll find that there is stuff in
some bsp layers which basically destroy
other bsp layers
this is not friendly
so
if you are creating a bsp layer or if
you're testing
it's worthwhile just seeing what happens
if you add that bsp layer in your
bblayers.com file but don't use it as
you select a different machine it should
still build
that's logically
consistent but quite often it doesn't
and usually the problem is with these bb
appends
if you have a bsp layer with a whole
bunch of bb pens
which
then interfere with
other recipes that you may be using in
other layers yeah the whole thing the
whole thing blows up
so okay right
i've just said that
another problem is dependencies so
quite often one layer depends on other
layers
and so when you're doing the
running the bit bake build bit bake
whatever
you get errors like this
could not include require recipes blah
blah
essentially the problem is then
that
linux imx
is in a different layer and we don't
have that layer so then we have to go
and scratch your hair a little bit work
out where linux imx is coming from
include that layer
it would be nice to avoid that
and it's very easy to avoid you just
need to put into the layer.conf file
your dependencies
so we depend on core and free scale
layer
and it turns out freescale layer is the
one that contains linux imax.inc
so be nice get your dependencies right
um
check your layer so there's a really
handy little script called
the octo check layer
and it's got various heuristics and
tests built into it
which will validate that your your layer
is at least halfway sane
so it's a good way to do this so it's a
good thing to do this you just run the
command pointed at your layer
and it chugs through in this case oh it
says
this is a bsp layer it knows that
because it's found a machine.com file
and
then it does various things and
hopefully you want to see at the end
pass
there you go there's a gold star for you
the final thing um and this is really
the biggest bugbear i have
with bsp layers from
many sources
when a company
so this this typically happens when you
you buy an off-the-shelf um single ball
computer or system on module from
many one of the many companies
the marketing department of the company
company often see the bsp layer as being
the showcase for their product
and so they will load as well as the bsp
stuff
they will load in demos
um splash screens with their company
logo in
all kinds of stuff which you really
don't want and don't care about
so
the bsp layer is not a market marketing
tool the bsp layer is just there to make
it work
if you want to have demos fine great i
like demos but put them into a separate
layer
so i can include the demo
initially just to see all the fine
things you do but when i produce my
thing
i want to do it my way not with your
funny splash screens and demos
um another thing then which kind of
relates back to this
thing here
so quite often when you
are using a bsp with a whole bunch of
stuff there are multiple layers
and it's
even though you put the layers here so
at least it will tell you that a layer
is missing it's even nicer if you can
actually load all the layers in one go
so
one common way to do this actually is to
use repo
so repo is from android but it's
basically just a wrapper around git
you give it a manifest file which is an
xml file with a list of get repositories
in you'd run repo it will clone them all
for you
and
a company called digi do quite do this
quite nicely so here's an example of a
repo from digi
and
that works quite nicely
oh and when you do that yeah so that
includes all these layers so metadigi
which is their bsp layer
meta freescale which has some stuff for
the
imx chips
some demos
met open embedded because it uses some
additional stuff from from metro open
embedded qt5 because we want to do some
graphical stuff
an sw update because we want a software
updater
so that's a good way of presenting
the
uh the features of your product without
putting everything into the bsp layer
oh final thing yes
you can sign up
for
yocto compatibility
so
you can actually get the the badge of
approval from the youtube developers
um you can give me a given couple there
be a give them a copy of your bsp
layer and
they're pretty nice people
they will
suggest some changes maybe
um but if it's perfect that will give
you the badge
and then having done that it would be
really nice to publish the layer
out this is the thing i was trying to
remember so this is the layer index
layers.openembedding.org
slash layer index
so then that would appear as a bsp
layout on there and then anybody in the
world can download your bsp and use your
fantastic
computer board
advantages to getting it right this is
kind of obvious
reduced development costs
help from the community
the yorktow developers are very very
keen to help people write vsps
happier users
more
easily integrated into other people's
products
so given that list you would wonder why
don't why is it that
there's a problem with bsps and answers
i don't know
but the advantages of getting the bsp
right are kind of overwhelming
and
that is basically it
so
any questions
or are you are you also totally
overwhelmed
so if i'm buying a board in which has a
which comes with a bsb would i need to
create my own bsp
no not in that case
i would use the bsp that i've been given
but i may want to make some changes
so i'll need to add some bb appends
because i want to use um
a later kernel version or some extra
features or whatever
so
as a user of a dev board
you will be typically modifying an
existing bsp rather than writing one
from scratch
exactly so yeah so the bsp you get from
the um the vendor i mean raspberry pi is
a good example so you get the raspberry
pi bsp
that has
um hooks in it for everything that
raspberry pi can do which is a vast
number of things
and then on top of that you just select
the particular features that you want
to make it into a drone or a
computer or whatever you want
yeah
uh so dts is the device tree source uh
it's a standard
um for all linux devices
um i'm not so familiar with vxworks
um but
so the device free so device tree dts
is
used throughout linux
for all architectures apart from x86
so x86 as we know is weird
but everything else
uses dts device trees
so you
yeah um
okay so
so coming from the audience then is that
yeah so
vx works
whenever vx works also uses dts device
tree files but they're not they're
they're similar to but not identical to
the linux dts files
um anyone else
no no
yeah
so yes the question is would you do this
for something like an arduino
and the answer is
more or less no
so the so yokto project
is
mostly for linux
based systems not to say you can't so
you can build um
uh zephyr yeah stuffer uh there is
support for for example zephyr which is
another real-time operating system
um
and in principle since it's just a build
system you could do it for anything
um
but in practice
yokto is mostly used for linux
so yes so more powerful things
32 and 64-bit processors with
quite a few hundred megabytes of ram
okay question where do you set the cpu
architecture
and other things yes um i kind of
skipped over that yeah so um
in the
um
so in in the
machine count file
you will
include tunings for whichever processor
you're having
so you'll have include for
um i can remember
arch 64
or um x or or x86 or whatever so it is
in the
excuse me you include the appropriate uh
machine tunings as part of your uh conf
file
okay
its
uh so the question is
how does yocto fit into the zephyr
um board support package
um
the the simple answer is i have no clue
i'm afraid um because i've not used
zephyr and i'm not really familiar with
the the support for that all i know is
that there is a meta-zephyr layer uh for
yocto and i see commits on the mail list
from time to time
but i've no real idea what it is that
they do
okay
so
yeah so the
so far as i understand um the
integration with the octo and zephyr is
exactly as with linux it's a bunch of bb
files and light metal layers and
whatever that support
uh that architecture but the details of
that i'm afraid i are beyond me
okay so we're pretty much out of time so
thank you all very much for uh turning
up and listening to me
and just before we go there's one little
thing i want to do i hope you don't mind
um i really want to do a selfie of
myself standing in front of an audience
which is not a thing i've done
in recent times
so
shield your faces if you don't appear in
my picture
there we go
just to prove there were people in the
room
so thank you all very much and see you
next year
[Applause]
you